let's have a project now it will help
you to tour they said right three
function values you've automatically
always got to the first in the lot so
anymore you had up just two binds it up
rotor so I've got three that just means
one middle namely midpoint okay now you
can see obviously just by looking at it
because there are nice neat number e
open D feel my height for each of these
trapezium is two but just in case you
yet or it's not so obvious how do we
work out this height well by this long
and divided by however many sub
intervals you have now is three function
values that's which is now the reason
why I do that is even goes easier in
this case you'll get terrible those
later on infractions not gonna do so
don't skip okay now what's the area I'm
going to be approximately equal to well
I've got the front and back to weave
down your formula okay I've got H on two
of the front leg which is too fun for
the students now what comes next you may
want to remember that ten sort of where
we're gonna drain we've got the first
two times all the ones in the middle and
the lost so what's the first one how
many middle function value so I have
just one
now because I've given you such an easy
function okay we can just do it walk
here but if you've got a sort of core
messy function it was complicated you
need to get a calculator out and work
out what all of these values actually
work it may be useful to you to write
yourself a table so they repeat that
this table values here right it's for
you to use
when your functions are outside
one in 13 50s now just out of interest
I'm going to put in its a decimal
approximation which I think it'd be
useful for us later on now that wasn't
so hard
okay what's the difference when you go
from three function values into define
well series whatever you know I'm gonna
have to work out radicular okay
so again it's going to be still five
minutes while I'm on and how many
something goes by huh so there's my life
which okay so now I can head into my
evaluation and changsu then f1 dog with
all of the middle ones
okay okay okay know what's happening
let's just not just get value but let's
see what's happening this approximation
was a value mr. Spivey Guto is decent
right
this was smaller why is it small because
it's concave up hmm this area this era
we had right the arrow was above the
wrath that's be an exaggeration you get
the idea okay so when you've got bigger
trapeziums that area is larger so as I
add more that's what my baby okay yes I
think what you mean like scale who may
be error neat bureaus warmer but see how
doesn't change what the error
objectively is like an actual just my
taste I lose
okay right okay pretty close but as you
add more trapeziums you add lots more
work and you don't get eaten war
benefits in terms of accuracy especially
when you compare it to something like
the treasure
okay we just so what's the area arrow
seven okay so if there's one thing that
I want to get across to you okay it's
that the two things how to get across to
you is just be careful with your
language it's super super super close
attention to what they're actually
asking your work out okay cuz if you
read this wrong you do all your Matt's
right and you get the wrong in it up or
something that you didn't okay so this
is the first thing to pay attention to
the second thing is remember where this
formula came from that why are we
doubling I know how much is twice
already but Tony again why are we
doubling
because they didn't doing the trapeziums
right you're doing this height then
you're doing again all right
and the reason why I keep emphasizing
that three views when we learned
Simpsons rule the next method of
approximating it is fiendishly similar
to this so you have to know really well
why is it a two and not four okay cuz we
get for why is it - I'm not a three okay
it's not the result that I'm looking for
it's how you get there okay or six for
that matter okay so please make sure you
have the actual for this trapezoidal
rule nice and my advice to you would be
to memorize it as quickly as you can
it's a it's a recipe for disaster
if you ever try and memorize two things
at the same time which I'm almost